the european union is a leader in
climate action how can we make the best
use of our leadership in the green
transition maintaining this leadership
would strengthen the competitiveness of
the european union's economy in the
future foresight helps policymakers to
make the most out of the green
transition by anticipating which
technologies are relevant for tomorrow
the core of the open strategic autonomy
is to become more autonomous and to
shape the world's future together with
partners
open strategic autonomy is an emerging
and cross-cutting issue that touches
many fields
how can the european union achieve that
in collaboration with over a hundred
experts we completed a comprehensive
foresight process
four different foresight scenarios on
the european union's global standing in
2040 highlight the uncertainties that
policymakers need to consider for the
future of the european union
the insights we gained help to future
proof european union policies we want
them to stand the test of time and
respond to the challenges of tomorrow
this work supported the commission's
2021 strategic foresight report learn
more about the challenges and
opportunities for the future of the
european union's open strategic autonomy
by reading the scientific report on our
website
you